Traduttore: Denise Cosentino
Revisore: Elena Montrasio
Le parole sono importanti.
Ci mettono in relazione,
danno forma al nostro pensiero.
Le parole della nostra lingua
sono straordinarie.
Sono sonore, evocative, ricche,
sono piene di storia,
di vibrazioni, di emozione,
sono sonore, sono evocative,
risuonano con la nostra storia.
E della bellezza della nostra lingua,
e del fatto che questa bellezza
vada tutelata, preservata, percepita,
nuovamente, vi parlerò.
Vi parlerò della marea montante
dell' "itanglese":
la mescolanza provinciale,
immotivata, spesso oscura,
di parole italiane e inglesi
che da pochi anni sta cominciando
a diventare comune.
Ma la prenderò un po' alla larga,
e comincerò a mostrarvi
alcuni motti latini.
Hanno motti latini sulle loro insegne
le maggiori Università del mondo,
e li mostrano con grande orgoglio.
Qui siamo in Australia,
qui siamo a Hong Kong,
e c'è un motto latino.
Nel Ghana, in Corea,
in Russia, in Svezia,
nel Regno Unito,
al King's College di Londra,
e nel Regno Unito a Oxford,
a Chicago, negli Stati Uniti.
Harvard dice "Veritas" nella sua insegna.
E non solo le Università, orgogliosamente,
dichiarano se stesse in latino.
Londra ha un motto latino,
Parigi ha un motto latino,
il Canada ha un motto latino,
il Queensland, in Australia,
ha un motto latino.
Ma non solo.
La Marina Americana dice:
"Semper fidelis",
L'avrete sentito, Semper fide!,
in mille film.
La Marina britannica parla in latino,
e perfino un'istituzione non certo nota
per essere passatista, come la NASA,
regala un motto latino
alle missioni Apollo.
Perché la sto facendo
così lunga con il latino?
E con i motti latini?
Perché se c'è un singolo posto al mondo
in cui un motto latino ci poteva stare,
è questo.
Eccolo! La culla, del latino.
Avete visto, invece,
qual è il recente marchio turistico
della città di Roma,
approvato e lanciato
dalla municipalità romana?
È questo.
(Risate)
Non si capisce neanche
come dobbiamo pronunciarlo.
"Rome, me and you?"
"Rome and you?"
Cos'è questo ammiccamento di bassa lega?
Cos'è questa contaminazione,
questo corto circuito fra due lingue,
che toglie il senso a ciascuna?
Cosa sono quelle 5 palle in alto?
(Risate)
(Applausi)
E uno si chiede: "Ma perché?"
(Risate)
Ma perché, nel momento in cui
se guardiamo i marchi turistici
di tutte le città del mondo,
non c'è nessuno che faccia
la cosa insensata
di storpiare il suo nome,
per promuoversi.
Da nessuna parte.
Solo a Roma.
Ma a proposito di storpiature,
vogliamo dare un'occhiata
al portale turistico
(Applausi)
appena lanciato dal Ministero
dei Beni Culturali.
Very bello. Pronto?
(Risate)
Cioè, non "Molto bello!"
o "Very beautiful!".
Collassiamo italiano e inglese
in maniera del tutto insensata.
Non piace a noi, e non piace
neanche agli anglofoni,
la cosa curiosa è questa.
Ma "Du ui still spik italian?"
Parliamo ancora italiano?
Sto parlando dell'italiano.
La lingua più romantica del mondo,
a proposito di "RoMe & You".
Strizzata d'occhio.
La lingua più romantica del mondo,
secondo 320 linguisti anglosassoni.
La quarta lingua più studiata al mondo.
E non studiano l'italiano
per fare affari:
lo studiano perché lo amano,
per la cucina, per la moda, per l'opera,
per l'arte, per la storia, per Dante.
Lo studiano per questo.
[Oggi la quarta lingua
più studiata al mondo,
dopo inglese, francese e spagnolo.
Lo dice il Ministero degli Esteri]
Stiamo parlando della lingua
degli angeli, secondo Thomas Mann.
[Sì, caro signore, per me non c'è dubbio
che gli angeli in cielo parlino italiano.]
Eppure... ecco, per esempio,
la pizza ha conquistato il mondo
continuando a chiamarsi pizza.
Qui vedete la mappa
delle pizzerie negli Stati Uniti
confrontata con la mappa dei negozi
che vendono hamburger o hot dogs.
Vince la pizza.
Ecco, se tutto il mondo
mangia e dice "pizza",
perché noi qui in Italia beviamo "wine"?
Guardate qua:
mangiamo "food" e beviamo "wine"
a Lucca, a Cernobbio,
a Catania, a Milano.
E la cosa è curiosa perché a New York,
se al Waldorf Astoria devono promuovere
la settimana del vino italiano,
dicono "vino".
Perché i ristoranti di New York,
belli ed eleganti,
che vendono cibo e vino,
dicono "vino".
Parliamo di un'altra eccellenza italiana.
Abbandoniamo il cibo,
e andiamo a parlare di moda.
Questo è quello che scrive
la maggiore rivista italiana di moda:
"il look curvy-friendly più glam
direttamente dalle passerelle
della fall-winter".
E vabbe', abbiamo capito che le stagioni
non sono più quelle di una volta;
(Risate)
ma spiegatemi perché devo chiamare
una donna opulenta "curvy",
come se fosse una strada
di montagna nel Grand Canyon,
e non "formosa", come sono formose
le nostre Veneri,
e le donne che vediamo
nei nostri ritratti rinascimentali.
Perché?
Curvy?!
Ma si vergognino! Non sono curvy!
Vogliamo parlare di pubblicità,
anzi, di "advertàising"?
Dunque, questa è la pagina pubblicitaria
di una vettura Renault in Spagna,
e parla spagnolo.
Questa è una pagina pubblicitaria
della medesima vettura in Francia,
e parla francese.
Questa è la stessa pagina
in Italia, e parla inglese.
Ci sono due sole parole italiane:
"Il Primo".
(Risate)
(Applausi)
Che cosa ci sta succedendo,
se perfino il sindacato
(Risate)
dice: "Torniamo alle nostre radici,
chiamiamoci -Landini questo - "Unions".
Unions, le radici del sindacato italiano?
Siamo sicuri?
È curioso perché oltre un italiano su due
non spiaccica una parola d'inglese.
Era il 60% nel 2012,
diciamo che ora sono il 58%.
Quindi non sappiamo l'inglese,
non lo sappiamo come Paese,
E si vede.
(Risate)
E qui c'è da sperare
che le competenze mediche
del signore o della signora
che ha compilato questo modulo della ASL
siano superiori
alle competenze linguistiche.
Eppure ogni giorno, per pigrizia,
per distrazione, per conformismo,
perché ci sembra moderno,
perché siamo provinciali,
usiamo una quantità
di parole inglesi non necessarie,
non profondamente inserite
nel tessuto della lingua italiana,
puramente accessorie e inutili.
Diciamo "call" invece di "telefonata",
diciamo "location" invece di "posto".
Ho sentito dire:
"Il Nazareno è la location
che Renzi ha scelto per gli incontri".
La sede di un partito è una "location"?
Diciamo "competitor" e "compilation",
diciamo "customer care" e "day by day".
Negli uffici si può sentir dire:
"Dobbiamo schedulare una conference call
per il fine tuning
della customer satisfaction,
con la business unit".
Quando basterebbe dire:
"Dobbiamo chiamare
Pippo, Franco e Gennaro
per mettere a posto questa faccenda
del servizio clienti".
Perché poi la business unit
è sempre Pippo, Franco e Gennaro!
(Applausi)
L'itanglese ormai lo parlano
non solo le imprese ma anche i media,
la pubblica amministrazione, il Governo.
Noi abbiamo una legge dello Stato
che si chiama "Jobs Act",
e vi assicuro che il fatto che si chiami
"Jobs Act" non l'ha resa più simpatica.
E ha obbligato gli speaker
dei telegiornali a dire "Jobat",
che è una roba che non esiste in natura.
Avremo, fra un po', una tassa in inglese
che non ci sarà più simpatica
perché ha un nome inglese.
Ecco: un paio di mesi fa,
dopo l'uscita del marchio romano,
io mi sono detta
che dovevo fare qualcosa.
Comunicare è il mio mestiere,
ho in mente due o tre
processi e strumenti
che possono essere efficaci,
ho pensato con i ragazzi del mio ufficio
di mettere in piedi un'iniziativa in rete
per fare sensibilizzazione, e militanza,
su questo problema.
Gratis, e senza spendere un soldo.
Semplicemente mettendoci
un po' di competenza
di comunicazione dell'ufficio,
e un po' di energia.
Questa petizione, che invitava
le pubbliche amministrazioni,
il Governo, le imprese, i media
a "Dirlo in Italiano",
era rivolta in prima istanza
all'Accademia della Crusca,
perché si facesse protagonista
di quest'opera di sensibilizzazione.
Ci aspettavamo un discreto riscontro,
ma non quello che è successo.
In meno di un mese hanno firmato,
mettendoci nome, cognome, indirizzo,
70.000 persone.
Hanno firmato giovani, anziani,
poliglotti e persone
che non spiaccicano l'inglese,
hanno firmato rettori e studenti,
hanno firmato traduttori,
insegnanti di italiano e di inglese,
splendidi professionisti e pensionati,
Hanno firmato italiani all'estero,
dicendo: "Che cosa state facendo
alla nostra lingua?"
E hanno firmato stranieri in Italia.
Hanno firmato da tutto il mondo:
da Singapore, da Gerusalemme, dal Perù,
dal Sudafrica e dal Nord Africa,
dal Canada, dall'Australia.
Una cosa commovente:
io ho passato ore a guardare
queste firme che crescevano,
e a leggere le motivazioni.
E vorrei farvene vedere qualcuna.
"L'italiano è un diritto
ma anche un dovere".
"Siamo in overload da fuffa".
"Se pensiamo scorrettamente
parliamo altrettanto scorrettamente.
Lavoro in una pubblica
amministrazione... Aiuto!"
"Firmo perché ho studiato
al liceo classico,
ma ora lavoro con gli economisti".
"Lavoro nella moda:
ho ricevuto una press release
per un happening di preview dei trend.
Non credo che ci andrò".
(Risate)
"Un ottimo italiano e un decente inglese
sono assai meglio
di uno scadente itanglese.
Shish!"
E sappiamo di chi stiamo parlando.
Questa è una delle più strepitose:
"Ho un nome straniero ma parlo italiano"
dice Chung Fei Wu da Roma.
"Firmo perché inizia a mancarmi
l'iridescenza del nostro linguaggio".
"Perché non vorrei mai sentir dire,
al mio funerale: che splendida location".
(Risate e Applausi)
"Firmo per Dante, Montale, Caproni,
Pavese, Bianciardi, Gadda..."
"Sono stufo di sentire relatori
che non sanno dire
the book is on the table,
ma si riempiono la bocca
di company profile",
e così succede.
"Firmo perché non credo
che chi dice cool sia cool".
"Firmo perché ho sentito
professori universitari
che dicono displayato
invece che visualizzato".
"Sto firmando perché non so l'inglese".
(Applausi)
"Firmo perché desidero capire
che cosa dicono i politici
che chiedono il mio voto".
"Era ora che qualcuno finalmente
prendesse questa iniziativa, ho 85 anni.
Grazie ai promotori".
Ecco, vi dicevo, un'eco
straordinaria e trasversale,
perché i mezzi di comunicazione di massa
hanno preso questa cosa
fatta a costo zero in rete,
e l'hanno amplificata.
E questa iniziativa è uscita
in oltre 130 articoli
sui giornali italiani,
con un consenso trasversale
inimmaginabile.
Ne hanno parlato insieme Gramellini
e Serra su La Stampa e su La Repubblica,
ma l'ha ripresa con grande plauso
anche Il Secolo d'Italia e l'Avvenire.
Ne ha parlato Wired
e ne ha parlato Vanity Fair,
ne ha parlato Famiglia Cristiana,
ne ha parlato il mensile del Touring,
ne ha parlato Oggi, e il direttore
ne ha fatto un editoriale.
Una trasversalità che si è estesa
a tutto l'arco costituzionale,
e anche un po' di qua e un po' là,
e che è andata in profondità
dalle testate più di nicchia e colte
a quelle più popolari.
E ha espresso un grande desiderio
di riappropriarci, con orgoglio
e consapevolezza, della nostra lingua.
Questa cosa è finita nei telegiornali,
mi è toccato mettermi la cipria sul naso
e andare a parlare ai tg.
È stata ripresa dalle radio,
sono stata intervistata
da una radio australiana,
da una irlandese.
Ecco, c'è bisogno di questo.
E tutto questo è qualcosa che nasce
dalla consapevolezza di ognuno di noi,
perché la lingua è ciò che noi costruiamo
in ogni momento del nostro parlare,
del nostro pensare e del nostro scrivere,
ogni giorno.
E quindi l'appello è,
teniamoci tutti stretti l'italiano.
E vi ricordo, in conclusione,
qualche motivo per farlo.
Adoperare parole italiane
aiuta a farsi capire da tutti,
ed è un fatto di democrazia,
perché farsi capire
è un fatto di democrazia.
Non ci vogliono regole,
non ci vogliono divieti:
ci vogliono buoni esempi.
E bisogna chiedere alle istituzioni
di dare il buon esempio.
La nostra lingua oltretutto
è un valore, è un fattore di promozione.
Dobbiamo venderla, spenderla,
portarla nel mondo
perché ci rappresenta.
E sapere più lingue,
togliamo ogni dubbio, è bellissimo:
protegge anche il cervello,
sapere più di una lingua.
Ma chi sa le lingue
le usa una alla volta.
L'itanglese, oltretutto, l'abbiamo visto,
è facile straparlare,
e quindi chi parla come mangia
parla meglio.
E poi è stato citato Leonardo
nel primo intervento di questa giornata,
Leonardo che definiva se stesso
"Homo sanza litterae"
perché scriveva in volgare,
cioè in italiano.
Da sempre la struttura, la forma,
l'iridiscenza della lingua italiana
ci aiuta a esprimere la nostra creatività.
Se rinunciamo a esprimerci
nella nostra lingua,
rinunciamo a esprimere
una delle peculiarità,
delle flessuosità,
delle magnifiche potenzialità
della nostra specifica
creatività italiana,
che ha radici nella sua lingua madre.
E ancora, se il nostro tessuto
linguistico è forte e solido
possiamo accogliere
qualche termine straniero, per carità!
Ma dobbiamo accoglierlo
dentro a un tessuto
che non è esploso e logorato
da perdite di senso
dovute a un eccesso
di termini stranieri mal usati.
Perché vi dico questo?
Perché l'italiano
siamo noi, gli italiani,
con la nostra identità,
le nostre radici, la nostra storia,
la nostra apertura verso il mondo,
che passa dalle nostre parole.
Grazie.
(Applausi)